so what of all the midnight showings and
I have been to this year this audience
was packed but they were actually
completely respectful the entire time
good job
Hobbit audience I like you guys The
Hobbit desolation of Smaug is directed
by Peter Jackson and stars a whole bunch
of people that I'm not even going to
bother naming this is of course the
continuation from the first Hobbit film
an unexpected journey that came out last
December the prequel to the original
Lord of the Rings trilogy three of my
favorite movies of all time here we pick
up with Bilbo Thorin and the rest of the
dwarves on their journey to the Lonely
Mountain as they tried to reclaim the
Arkenstone and there just might be a
dragon in the way
now the first Hobbit film I enjoyed I
did think it could have been a little
bit better some of the pacing was a
little bit lacking and there were things
that I thought could have been improved
so when I went into this film I had
slightly muted expectations but my first
initial thought when I left the theater
was that's more like it
this film is tremendously better vastly
improved everything about this film
I thought flowed so much better there
was a lot more action and the action
felt like it was filmed in a way that
was so much more interesting
particularly a barrel sequence early on
in the movie that had members of the
audience like doing that laughter when
something is so awesome on the screen
that you start laughing because it's so
cool and you just get so into it now in
this film you get introduced to some
characters that are not in the original
Hobbit book and some fans have been
upset about that I'm fine with it as
long as it improves the movie if it adds
something to the movie namely Legolas
who you know is a welcome return for me
because I loved him in the original
films every time he was on this screen
he just infused testosterone and awesome
badassery into this movie that wouldn't
have been there if his presence wasn't
there and I thought he was great in this
movie this is definitely Orlando Bloom
signature roll in my opinion it's cool
to see him kind of before he gets used
to dwarfs because he was a big pal of
gillies in the original films but it
took a while for them to get to know
each other and this film you get to see
him where he still kind of has that
prejudice towards dwarves and this is
Legolas before he was a little bit more
heartfelt he's just this quiet cold
warrior and I thought that was such a
benefit to this movie as a film this
just felt more complete it felt like
characters were in a place that made you
more invested and some critics have said
this film suffers from middle I
you know where there isn't as much of a
conclusion and certain things are left
in the air and how that bugs some people
I adore that that was one of my favorite
things about the Empire Strikes Back
being the middle film allows for no
finality which in turn breaks the mold
of common cinema making it more
interesting to me see where most films
have that stereotypical beginning middle
and end you can see where everything is
going to fall into place this film
doesn't follow that formula and so I
found it all the more enthralling now
one of the things that I think
definitely improved this for me this
time around was I opted to see the film
in 2d last time I saw the film in 48
frames per second and it was a very big
distraction for me and I wasn't able to
really enjoy the film as much as I
possibly could have I think the film
looks great in 2d I wasn't distracted
the special effects thus looked better
and more realistic because of that also
there seem to be more prosthetic orcs in
this film with makeup and things like
that that made it more realistic to me
and that was something that I could
enjoy more because a lot of the orcs in
the first one we're like all CGI and
speaking to the CGI there are a few
shots in this movie where you can really
tell it's CGI namely there's a few shots
where they replace Legolas with a CGI
human and generally when you tend to
fully CGI a human being even though he
isn't health it tends to look
unrealistic also there's a romance in
the film between Evangeline Lilly's
character and another character which I
won't spoil that I felt was kind of
cheesy and a little bit shoehorned in
there and I know her character is added
to the movie and it seemed kind of like
they just added her to create this
romance so the film could have a romance
which it seems like all sweeping
adventures need nowadays but it didn't
really feel like it needed to be there
although I did like her character and I
thought she was really awesome the drama
just felt more rich the characters felt
more realized Thorin again is definitely
one of my favorite elements of this
movie even though you can kind of tell
that he's the like the Viggo Mortensen
replacement speaking of Thorin I will
say that it seemed a lot of the times
that Thorin was actually the main
character in this movie and not Bilbo
some people may be upset by that because
obviously Bilbo is the main character of
The Hobbit book but here he kind of
feels second to Thorin which is
something that maybe might bother some
but I didn't mind because I liked the
character of Thorin more than the
character of Bilbo also Benedict
Cumberbatch as the dragon that is some
of the coolest CGI I've ever seen in my
life that was an extremely well realized
CGI creation I totally bought that
dragon as a
presence and those scenes were fantastic
overall this was a hugely enjoyable
movie for me and I was very surprised by
how much I liked it because even though
I loved the Lord of the Rings trilogy I
thought the first topic film could have
been improved this film I think Peter
Jackson took a lot of the things that
people said last time around to harp he
changed up the pacing there was more
action the characters felt more well
realized this is also his shortest
middle-earth film and I think that
helped I'm gonna give the hobbit the
desolation of smaug and a - I really
think it's a vast improvement on the
first one so guys what's your favorite
middle-earth film and that includes the
old cartoons if you want to talk about
those - because I watch the old Hobbit
cartoons that great test avenge I won't
ever do that again guys as always thanks
very much for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes